- [Voiceover] So I'm going to ask you
what I think it is an
interesting question.
Have you ever sat in a
room at room temperature,
lets say it's around
70 degrees Fahrenheit.
And watched a glass of liquid water
spontaneously have ice in the middle?
And I'm guessing that
you have never seen that.
Of course you wouldn't see
ice spontaneously form,
specially if the room is
at 70 degrees Fahrenheit.
If it's above the freezing
temperature of water.
But my question to you is, why not?
Because that does not seem to defy
any of the laws of physics,
the Newtonian physics.
Or even the first law of Thermodynamics.
Lets just think about how
that actually could occur.
Lets imagine a bunch of water molecules,
in their liquid state.
So, I have a bunch of water
molecules in their liquid state.
I'm gonna do a good number of them.
And, they have some temperature.
Remember, temperature's just
about average kinetic energy.
But, each of these, are gonna
have their own velocities,
their own momentums.
So, they're all going
to be bouncing around
in different ways.
And, they have their
hydrogen bonds between them.
That's why water is liquid
state at room temperature,
as opposed to gas.
You got some hydrogen bonds between them.
But I'm not gonna get too
fixated on that just yet.
Now, you can imagine
they're all bouncing around
in random ways,
but there is some probability that they
interact just in the right way
that maybe this molecule right over here
is able to hit this one in the right way.
So it transfers most of its
momentum to the faster molecule.
And so this one actually
looses some of its momentum.
And it slows down.
And just as that's happening
in the neighborhood of it,
one of the other molecules is able
to transfer most of its
momentum to some other molecule.
So it too slows down.
So they all have much smaller momentum.
And then maybe this one,
at the exact same time
is able to do it.
So it slows down, so it slows down here.
And then the other ones that got
the momentum transferred to them,
they're all moving faster now.
So lets say that one got their
momentum transferred to it.
That one got momentum transferred to it.
And, this one got momentum
transferred to it.
And now, these molecules right over here,
their momentum is small enough,
their velocities are small enough,
that the hydrogen bonds
really take over and they're able to start
forming some form of a lattice structure.
They're getting cold
enough, you could say,
to actually freeze.
So these are turning into ice.
Why can't that happen?
What I've just described,
I'm just talking about
things colliding and
transferring their momentum.
I'm talking about energy not
being created or destroyed.
So it seems to fit in with the
first law of Thermodynamics.
So it seems like, theoretically,
maybe it is possible
for ice to spontaneously form.
Or maybe another way to think about it,
maybe it is possible to
start off with a system
that is fairly uniform.
It has an average temperature here.
But maybe a cold pocket could form
by the rest of it turning hot.
So, maybe initially, all
of the water is 70 degrees.
So, everything I'm showing you
is a neutral 70 degrees Fahrenheit.
But maybe, there's some
probability that spontaneously,
I have no creation or loss of energy,
but some of the energy from the middle
gets put into the outside, so it warms up.
So, let me do this in a different color.
So maybe all of this water outside,
maybe this is a top-down
view of the water.
Maybe all of this water heats up.
Maybe all that water heats up.
And all the water in
the middle, cools down.
But they have the same total,
they have the same total kinetic energy.
So I haven't created or lost energy,
it's just happened to
be that, spontaneously,
I was able to transfer energy
from the middle, outwards.
And even as the middle
got a little bit colder,
I was able to transfer
more and more energy
from the cold, the cold water,
to the hot water.
And it gets ordered in this way.
This is actually, it feels possible,
due to some of the physics
that we already know.
But, some thoughtful folks,
like these gentlemen here,
this is Carnot, considered
the father of Thermodynamics.
Kelvin, Rudolf Clausius.
They repeatedly observed,
this doesn't seem to be
happening in nature.
Specially when you get
to the characters like
Kelvin and Clausius.
They're saying, "hey look,
it doesn't look like we're
"observing transfer of heat
"from cold to hot.
"And, since we're not observing it,
"lets just add our own Second
Law of Thermodynamics".
The Second Law of
Thermodynamics is really based
on empirical observation.
And the Second Law of Thermodynamics,
according to Rudolf Clausius,
and I'm gonna paraphrase this,
is that we don't see spontaneous,
let me write this down.
Second Law of
Thermodynamics.
He said, we don't see
a spontaneous transfer
of heat from cold areas to hot areas.
So Second Law of Thermodynamics.
So no transfer, no spontaneous.
We can use work,
like things like refrigeration equipment
to make heat flow
from cold to hot and cool something down.
But no spontaneous transfer,
transfer of heat,
from cold to hot.
And maybe I'll underline hot
in orange right over here.
And this was just really
based on observation,
because we don't spontaneously
see this happening,
we don't see the water
randomly organizing itself
into a hot region and a cold region,
and getting so cold that maybe
some of it will spontaneously freeze.
What we do observe is that
if I were to put ice water
in the middle of a room
at room temperature,
I'm gonna see the other way.
I'm gonna see transfer of heat
from, let me draw a cup here.
from the warmer regions
to the colder regions.
So, these are ice cubes right over here.
And,
this is the water.
This is the water right over here.
We're gonna see the
transferred heat the other way,
from the cold regions, to the hot regions.
Now, this was an empirical observation
and it seemed to hold
up to experimentation.
But why do we actually see that?
And it turns out, that there's some
super, super, duper,
duper, small probability
that this could actually happen.
Remember in real systems
that we're talking about.
And Thermodynamics is
really the study of systems
more than individual molecules
that we're talking about.
Any system we're talking about,
we're talking about way more molecules,
way more actors than just
three molecules here.
We could be talking about...
Well, if you look at
the number of molecules
in a glass of water,
you're looking at things with
20, 24, 25 zeros,
depending on the size
of your glass of water.
So you're looking at a huge,
huge number of molecules.
And so statistically.
And the didn't think
about things statistically
until Boltzmann comes along.
But statistically, the odds
of this happening are so low.
Specially when you're thinking about,
I'm not talking about
just three molecules,
I'm talking about
way, way more than three molecules
that you're just never
going to actually see it.
And you can think about this,
if we were to allow
ourselves to look at the
molecular level of things.
To not just look at the macro level.
You could see why this is.
So, if you,
if you were to have some
type of a container.
Let me draw a container here.
If you were to have a container.
And you have, on the left-hand side,
lets say you start with a bunch
of molecules that are hot.
So they have a high kinetic energy.
So these are, these have
a high average kinetic energy here.
These molecules.
And,
on the right side of the container,
you have, maybe some molecules.
And maybe they're the
same type of molecule,
but they have low kinetic energy.
So their temperature,
on average they have a
lower kinetic energy.
They might have a few that
have high kinetic energy.
But on average, the have
a lower kinetic energy.
So we see that the, we see,
that the temperature here is lower.
So let me write this down.
Right now where we're starting off,
this has a lower temperature.
While the left-hand side
has a higher temperature.
Now what's going to happen?
These molecules, they can
interact with each other.
They're gonna bounce into each other.
The things with high kinetic energy,
they're gonna bump into the things
with low kinetic energy.
And all of these things are also going
to get mixed together.
But even if somehow you weren't mixing it,
these things would be bumping into these
and transferring their momentum.
So, as time goes on you're going to have,
you're going to have a system
that looks more like this.
Where all of them are going to have
more of a medium,
or on average, a medium kinetic energy.
There's still gonna be differences
in their kinetic energies,
but they're not gonna
be divided in this way
between left and right.
So you're gonna see it all mixed in,
and you're gonna see that,
neither the left of the right
is going to have a higher temperature.
And so what is the net effect?
Well we had a transfer of energy
from the hotter molecules
to the colder molecules.
So, that energy that we're talking about,
that is heat.
We use Q to denote the heat.
We have a transferred
energy from hot to cold.
It's statistically
unlikely, very unlikely,
bordering on impossible,
but there's an infinitely
small chance it happens,
it's just it wont be observed.
Then you could go the other way,
but that's not what we see.
What we're talking about many, many, many,
not even millions.
Millions of millions
of millions of millions
of molecules.
You're gonna see the ones
with the higher kinetic energy
on average mix in and transfer it
to the ones with lower kinetic energy.
And so that's why they were able to say
"hey we don't see any
spontaneous transfer of heat
"from cold to hot".
It is always going from,
It is always going from hot to cold.